ah Brazil the beautiful sunkissed home
of Pele hairless genitalia and the
world's largest Jared Leto statue to
show my dedication to the legions of
Brazilian Deadpool fans
I've spent up to 20 minutes on Google
Translate as well as countless hours
watching telenovelas to teach me
everything about your official language
that's right but I see you this sexy red
spandex task learn to speak Portuguese
all right
hopefully I get the accent right here
goes vas a cameo connoisseur presenter
on our sson heritage SEO nuna comic-con
Brazil voman Darmstadt Oh odorous mas o
menos Leonardo's producer kupuna como
mobility which Pelle as a guru shishya
cinta de leche von van sapelo Co Co Co
Co Masha Kieran Quebec CEO Jeffrey Suraj
Emile Apache device a comprar dementia
gratis innovate Costa nada SOC najran
contrato de defensa se prepara para
Garuda Apache no Baku mission Falacci up
sign Sparky Hamada season 5 cocoon
gossip resembling a mo kamo Mo Kio
temple ami emoji data hidden samba pelon
Familia specific a manger Swan mine
Karen alpha zone puta the Maya or Gullu
they'll also pie ish it's a my off to do
to just focus on modelers prism suggest
primera vase or Chima I won't ever say
I'm a Sookie be don't happen our own
yeah you just custom Majorca look me
straight in the nipples and tell me I
didn't just nail that now what are you
waiting for go to the website below to
reserve your spot and you're sure to be
the talk of South Paulo space is limited
so best hurry because I think we can all
agree there's nothing like a wild day or
night in Brazil to make a special memory
that you'll cherish forever
just ask the 2016 US men's swimming team
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up
Jojo